foreign
rapidly evolving technological landscape
artificial intelligence has emerged as
the driving force behind Innovation
transforming Industries and reshaping
the way we interact with machine and
data as businesses seek to harness the
power of AI to enhance their Production
Services the demand for skilled air
Engineers has increased a well-crafted
engineer resume not only showcases your
technical skills but also serves as a
crucial tool to make a lasting
impression on potential employees
in this video we will be talking about
artificial intelligence resuming in this
video we will be covering AI engineer
resume format and structure what to
incorporate in a resume for AI role how
to create resumes some of your objective
important skills for AI Engineers how to
write your experience education systems
and at last we'll cover some tips for
air engineering assuming but before we
begin let me ask you a quick question
what is the primary role of an AI
engineer a creating artistic designs for
websites B developing software
applications for mobile devices see
designing and implementing a Solutions
or D managing social media marketing
campaigns now you can pause this video
and answer in the comment section below
so let's start with the first topic
which is air engineer resume format and
structure
so format an organization of AI
Engineers you may neglecting the
Aesthetics and arrangement of your
resume while solely concentrating on its
textual details might waste your efforts
irrespective of your qualifications for
the position no hiring agent desires to
invest their time to go through a poorly
crafted and disorganized resume rather
ensure the arrangement of your content
follows a straightforward structure and
dedicates some time to format it in a
manner that enhances readability this
approach will guarantee that each
recruiter and hiring manager can pursue
your resume effortlessly so what to
incorporate in a resume for an
artificial engineer role so the
essential segments within a resume for
an artificial intelligence position
encompasses first professional
experience
this is where you tell about the jobs
you have done before if you have worked
on AI related projects that's the place
to talk about them you can mention what
you did what skills you used and what
you learned from those experiences then
contact details this is like sharing
your phone number email address and
maybe even your LinkedIn profile it's
how the company can get in touch with
you if they want to talk more about the
job third is skill set
here you list down the things you are
good at for an a engineer this could be
stuff like programming languages python
for example machine learning deep
learning data analysis or any other
technical skills you have all right
after that educational background
this is where you talk about your
schooling and any degrees you have
earned like telling them what you have
studied and what you have learned other
than this you can include Awards and
certifications personal projects and
languages Etc now coming to the third
point which is how to create a resume or
objective for an AI engineer role
so when you're making a similar
objective for your resume
as an AI engineer here's what you can do
resume a summary this is a short
paragraph that gives a quick overview of
your a related experience skills and
what makes you good fit for the job
for example dedicated AI engineer with a
strong background in machine learning
and deep learning algorithms experience
in developing a solutions for diverse
application
proficient in Python tensorflow and data
analysis seeking to contribute expertise
to an Innovative Tech Team so this is
how you can create a resume summary
now let's understand how to create a
objective resume objective
so this is a brief statement of your
career goals and what you want to
achieve in the AI field so an example of
resume objective is
spark a engineer looking to apply
academic knowledge in Practical projects
eager to learn and collaborate in
Dynamic AI focused environment to
enhance skills in algorithm development
and data manipulation
remember both the summary and objective
should be concise and focus on
highlighting your AI skills and what you
can bring to the job so this is the
summary
summary or resume objective all right
now moving on to the next topic which is
important skills for an AI engineer so
now we will be discussing some of the
important skills important for an a
engineer
first would be neural network
architecture
so Proficiency in designing implementing
various neural network structures to
solve complex problems this is the first
skill and second is algorithm
optimization algorithm optimization is
the ability to enhance and fine-tune
algorithms for improved efficiency and
performance in AI application third is
NLP that is natural language processing
skill in developing models that
understand and generate human language
enabling applications like chat boards
and language translation next is
statistical analysis statistical
analysis the capability to analyze and
interpret data using statistical methods
crucial for making informed decisions in
AI projects next important skill for AI
engineer is deep learning
strong grasp of deep learning techniques
enables the creation of advanced a
models for tasks like image recognition
and predictive analysis the next skill
is tensorflow by torch familiarity with
popular deep learning Frameworks for
building and training AI models is also
essential for an AI engineer
the next is computer vision applying
understanding of principles in computer
vision encompassing image recognition
detection of objects and segmentation of
images is also an important or essential
skill for an AI engineer so if you are
interested in becoming an AIML engineer
then check our produce post-gadget
program in Ai and ml to elevate your
career designed to understand complex
Concepts such as machine learning deep
learning natural language processing
computer vision and generative AI this
certification equips you with essential
skills for success in this Dynamic field
led by industry experts you will gain
access to Dedicated live sessions that
delve into the latest trends in AI
including generative modeling chat gbt
and explainable AI join us to expand
your knowledge enhance your expertise
and unlock exciting possibilities in the
world of AI and ml engineering
also listen what a Learners has to say
about our course we need to keep
updating your skills the course material
was comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning alright so this was about
important skills for an AI engineer now
let's move on to the next topic which is
how to write your work experience for AI
engineer assuming so while writing the
work experience section for an a
engineer resume you can structure it in
this way first
position name this is where you state
your job title during your time in the
company it could be machine learning
engineer AI researcher or any relevant
title that accurately reflects your role
then the company name provide the name
of the company or organization where you
were employed this gives a clear idea of
the context of your work after that
dates mention the period you worked in
this position include both the month and
year of your start and end dates this
helps employers understand your tension
following that responsibilities and
achievements this is the heart of your
work experience section
here you will describe what you did in
your role and what you accomplished
this is your chance to Showcase your
impact and contributions but now the
question arises what if I do not have
any work experience so in that case you
can write about internships or volunteer
experience
if you have taken part in internships
even if they aren't directly focused on
AI make sure to talk about them
similarly if you have done any volunteer
work and that lets you showcase skills
relevant to AI include that too then you
can include personal projects if you
have created your own AI models
developed apps or Taken part in open
source projects on your own this is a
great chance to highlight that what you
have accomplished you can also include
certifications if you have earned any
certifications that are linked to air or
programming even if they weren't Given
In traditional education institutions
make sure to mention them when composing
your CV or resume ads crucial to
consider the perspective of a recruiter
if they encounter extensive paragraphs
that are difficult to navigate they
could become frustrated and move on to
the next CV employ bullet points to
outline your roles main responsibilities
emphasizing technical skills software
skills and knowledge whenever possible
keep your points short and to the point
then now let's discuss the education
section
in your AI engineer resume the education
section is where you provide information
about your academic background
here's how to effectively write about
your education
first you can do is degree type and
major so first point you can write like
this degree type and major after that
University name then ears studied then
GPA GPA or percentage whatever is
preferred in your Institution
the education section allows potential
employers to understand your academic
background and any specialized knowledge
that is important to AI engineer role
you are pursuing all right
so now coming to the tips for a engineer
resume part
so now we will be discussing some tips
for a engineer resume
so first tip is highlight AI skills
emphasizing skills like machine learning
deep learning and programming languages
python for example they show you're
ready for a tasks second is Project
power if you have worked on AI projects
mention them it could be class projects
or personal ones they prove your
practical abilities
third is tailor to job
adjust your resume for each job
highlight skills and experiences that
match what the job requires quantify
achievements use number to Show
achievements like improved accuracy by
20 it is more impactful using words is a
good practice in resume then the last
one is use keywords it is one of the
most important step for algener resume
many companies use softwares to scan
resumes use terms from the job
descriptions to improve visibility
so these were some of the tips for a
engineer resuming
so in conclusion keep it concise
engaging and tailored to make a lasting
impression on potential employees
good luck in trading a compelling resume
that reflects your a expertise and sets
you on the path to a rewarding career
alright guys with that we have come to
the end of this topic if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
it will help you all thanks for watching
stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here